Un público, según lo que observó Dewey hace tiempo, se constituye
a través de la discusión y el debate. Si vamos a poner
a la tiranía de las asunciones en entredicho, y
evitar el dogma, el campo de lo no cuestionado, entonces
debemos estar dispuestos a someter a nuestras propias asunciones
al debate y la discusión. Es con este espíritu
con el que me uno a una discusión de uno de los
temas críticos de nuestro tiempo, digamos, cómo
movilizar diferentes formas de capital para el
proyecto de la construcción del estado.
Para poner las asunciones claramente, el capitalismo,
tras 150 años, se ha vuelto aceptable, y también lo ha sido la
democracia. Si miramos al mundo de 1945, y
observamos el mapa de las economías capitalistas y
los entes políticos democráticos, éstos eran la rara excepción,
no la norma. La cuestión ahora, sin embargo, es tanto
acerca de qué forma de capitalismo y qué tipo de
participación democrática. Pero debemos reconocer
que este momento viene dado por un raro consenso
de asunciones, y eso provee la base para un
tipo de acción, porque el consenso de cada momento
nos permite actuar. Y es necesario, sin importar
cómo de frágil o provisional sea nuestro consenso,
ser capaces de seguir adelante.
Pero la mayoría del mundo no se beneficia
ni del capitalismo ni de los sistemas democráticos. La mayor parte
del mundo experimenta el estado como represivo,
como una organización preocupada por la negación
de los derechos, por la negación de la justicia, más que
por proveerla. Y en términos de experiencia de
capitalismo, hay dos aspectos que el resto del
mundo experimenta. Primero, la industria extractiva.
Diamantes de sangre, esmeraldas de contrabando, maderas, que son
extraídos directamente de los más pobres. Segundo, la
asistencia técnica. Y la asistencia técnica
puede impactaros, pero es la peor forma de la actualidad,
de la fea cara del mundo desarrollado a los
países en desarrollo. Decenas de billones de dólares
son supuestamente gastados en capacidad constructiva con
personas que reciben pagos de hasta 1,500 dólares por día, quienes
son incapaces de pensar creativamente, u
orgánicamente.
La siguiente asunción -- y por supuesto los eventos del
7 de Julio, expreso mi más profunda simpatía, y antes
de eso, el 11 de Septiembre -- nos ha recordado que no
vivimos en tres mundos diferentes.
Vivimos en un mundo. Pero eso se dice fácilmente, pero
no estamos haciendo frente a las implicaciones del
mundo en el que vivimos. Y eso es, que
si queremos un mundo, este mundo
no puede basarse en enorme bolsillos de exclusión, y
luego inclusión para algunos. Debemos finalmente llegar
a pensar sobre las premisas de un mundo realmente
global, en relación con el régimen de derechos
y responsabilidades y cuentas que
son de ámbito realmente global. De otro modo estaremos
dejando pasar este momento abierto en la historia, donde tenemos
un consenso tanto en la forma de la política como en la
forma de la economía.
¿Cuál es una de estás organizaciones a seleccionar?
Tenemos tres términos críticos: economía, sociedad civil
y el estado. No haré frente a los
dos primeros, salvo para decir que una transferencia no crítica de
asunciones, de un contexto a otro, solo puede
provocar el desastre. La economía, enseñada en la mayoría de
las universidades de élite, es prácticamente inútil en
mi contexto. Mi país está dominado por
la economía de la droga y una mafia. Los libros de texto sobre economía no
funcionan en mi contexto, y tengo muy pocas
recomendaciones de alguien sobre como establecer
una economía legal. La pobreza de nuestro
conocimiento debe convertirse en la primera base del movimiento
hacia adelante, y no la imposición del marco que
funciona en la base del modelado matemático, por
el cual tengo un enorme respeto. Mis colegas del
Johns Hopkins estuvieron entre los mejores.
Lo segundo, en vez de debatir sin fin sobre cual
es la estructura del estado, por qué no
simplificamos y decimos, ¿cuáles son las funciones
que el estado en el siglo 21 debe cumplir?
Clare Lockhart y yo estamos escribiendo un libro sobre esto,
esperamos compartirlo ampliamente --
y lo tercero es que podríamos construir incluso un
índice para medir comparativamente como de bien estas
funciones, con las estaríamos de acuerdo, están siendo
realizadas en diferentes lugares.
¿Así que cuáles son estas funciones? Proponemos 10. Y
su legítimo monopolio a través de la violencia,
el control administrativo, la gestión de
finanzas públicas, la inversión en capital humano, la provisión de
derechos ciudadanos, la provisión de infraestructura,
la gestión de los activos tangibles e intangibles
de estado a través de la regulación, la creación del
mercado, los acuerdos internacionales -- incluyendo
préstamos públicos -- y lo más importante, el papel de la ley.
No lo elaboraré. Espero que las preguntas me den
una oportunidad. Esto es un objetivo factible,
básicamente porque contrariamente a la
asunción generalizada, yo discutiría que sepamos como hacer
esto. ¿Quién habría imaginado que Alemania estaría
unida o fuera democrática hoy, si se
mira desde la perspectiva del Oxford de
1943? Pero la gente de Oxford se preparó para una
Alemania democrática y se comprometió a la planificación. Y
hay montones de otros ejemplos.
Ahora para hacerlo -- y esto trae este
grupo -- tenemos que repensar la noción de capital.
Capital -- la forma menos importante de capital, en
este proyecto, es el capital financiero -- dinero. Dinero
no es capital en la mayoría de los
países desarrollados. Sólo es dinero. Porque carece de
formas institucionales, organizativas y de gestión para
convertirlo en capital. Y lo que se requiere es
la combinación de capital físico, capital institucional,
capital humano -- y la seguridad, por supuesto,
es crítica -- pero también lo es la información.
Ahora, el tema que debería preocuparnos aquí, y
ese es el reto que me gustaría plantear
a este grupo, es de nuevo, toma 16 años en vuestros
países producir alguien con un grado BS (diplomatura científica).
Toma 20 años producir alguien con un doctorado.
El primer desafío es replantear, fundamentalmente,
el tema del tiempo. Necesitamos repetir las
modalidades que hemos heredado? Nuestros sistemas
educativos han sido heredados del siglo XIX. ¿Qué
es lo que debemos hacer fundamentalmente para
retomar un proyecto, ese capital en formación es
rápido? La mayoría absoluta de la población
mundial tiene menos de 20, y está creciendo
más grande y más rápidamente. Necesitan maneras diferentes
de ser abordados. Diferentes maneras de ser
emancipados. Diferentes maneras de ser cualificados. Y
eso es lo primero.
Lo segundo es que vosotros resolvéis problemas, pero no estáis
abordando vuestra responsabilidad global. Os habéis mantenido
al margen de los problemas de corrupción. Sólo
queréis ambientes limpios donde funcionar. ¿Pero
si no pensáis sobre los problemas de
corrupción, quién lo hará? Os mantenéis alejados del diseño
para el desarrollo. Sois grandes diseñadores, pero vuestros
diseños son egoístas. Es para vuestro propio uso
inmediato. El mundo en el que yo opero, opera con
diseños robre carreteras, o presas, o aprovisionamiento de
electricidad que no ha sido revisitado en 60
años. Esto no está bien. Requiere pensamiento.
Pero particularmente, lo que necesitamos más que nada
de este grupo es llevar a vuestra imaginación
a influenciar en los problemas en la manera en la que la "meme"
se supone que debe trabajar. Tal como el trabajo sobre paradigmas,
mostró hace tiempo -- Trabajo de Thomas Kuhn -- es en
la intersección de ideas en la que los nuevos desarrollos --
verdaderos avances -- ocurren. Y espero que este
grupo sea capaz de hacer frente al tema del
estado, y desarrollo, y al empoderamiento de la
mayoría de los pobres del mundo, a través de estos medios.
Gracias.
Chris Anderson: Ashraf, hasta hace poco tú
fuiste el ministro de finanzas de Afganistán, un
país justo en el medio del programa de gran parte del mundo.
¿Va a conseguirlo el país? ¿Florecerá
la democracia? ¿Qué es lo que más te asusta?
Ashraf Ghani: Lo que más me asusta es -- eres tú.
Tu falta de compromiso. (Risa) Me preguntas,
sabes que siempre doy un respuesta no convencional.
No. Ahora en serio, el tema de Afganistán primero
debe ser visto -- al menos -- con una perspectiva
de 10 a 20 años. Hoy el mundo de la globalización
va rápido. El tiempo se ha comprimido. Y el espacio
no existe para la mayoría. Pero en mi mundo --
sabes, cuando fui de vuelta a Afganistán tras 23
años, el espacio se había expandido. Toda forma concebible
de infraestructura se vino abajo. Monté --
viajé -- viajé entre dos ciudades que solían
tomar tres horas y ahora tomó 12. Así que lo primero es
cuando la escala es así, necesitamos reconocer que
tan sólo las cosas simples que son infraestructura --
se tardan seis años en crear infraestructura. En
nuestro mundo. Cualquier tipo de elemento significativo. Pero la
modalidad de la atención, o "qué esta pasando
hoy, qué está pasando mañana."
Lo segundo es, cuando un país ha sido sometido a
una de las más inmensas, formas brutales de ejercicio
de poder -- tuvimos al ejercito rojo durante 10 años
continuos, 110.000 efectivos. Aterrorizando literalmente. El
cielo. Cada, cada afgano ve al cielo como un fuente
de temor. Fuimos bombardeados. Prácticamente fuera
de la existencia. Entonces, decenas de miles de personas
son entrenadas en terrorismo. En todos los bandos.
Estados unidos, Gran Bretaña, unidos, por
ejemplo, el servicio de inteligencia egipcio entrena
miles de personas en resistencia y terrorismo
urbano. Como explotar, como convertir una bicicleta en
un instrumento de terror. Como convertir un burro, un
carro de caballos, cualquier cosa. Y los rusos, igualmente.
Así que, cuando la violencia erupciona en un país como
Afganistán, es por ese legado. Pero
tenemos que entender que hemos tenido una suerte
increíble. Quiero decir, yo, realmente no puedo creer cuanta suerte
tengo de estar aquí, de pie en frente de vosotros, hablando.
Cuando me uní como ministro de finanzas, creí que
las opciones de vivir más de 3 años
no serían más del 5 por ciento. Esos eran
riesgos. Merecían la pena.
Pienso que podemos hacerlo, y la razón por la que podemos
es la gente. Ves, porque -- Te
doy una estadística. El 91 por ciento de los hombres en
Afganistán, el 86 por ciento de las mujeres, escuchan al menos
tres estaciones de radio al día. En términos de su
discurso, en términos de su sofisticación de
conocimiento del mundo, creo que -- me atrevería
a decir -- son mucho más sofisticados que
los americanos rurales con graduados universitarios, y la mayoría
de los europeos. Porque el mundo les interesa.
¿Y cuál es su inquietud predominante?
El abandono. Los afganos se ha vuelto profundamente
internacionalistas.
Sabes, cuando volví en diciembre de 2001, no
tenía ninguna intención de trabajar con el gobierno
afgano. Porque he vivido como un nacionalista.
Y les dije -- mi gente, con los americanos aquí,
los -- separados, separados. Sí, tengo un puesto de
asesor con la Naciones Unidas. Fui a través de 10 provincias
afganas muy rápido. Y todo el mundo me contaba
ellos -- era un mundo diferente. Sabes,
participan -- ven la participación, participación global,
como algo absolutamente necesario para el futuro
de la gente normal. Y lo que le
le preocupa más al afgano común es -- Clare
Lockhart está aquí, ella -- así que narraré una
discusión que tuvo con una mujer iletrada en el
norte de Afganistán. Y esa mujer dijo que
no le preocupaba si tendría comida en su mesa.
Le preocupaba si había un
plan para el futuro. Donde sus hijos podrían
tener realmente una vida diferente.
Eso me da esperanza.
CA: Cómo va Afganistán a proveer
un ingreso alternativo a las muchas personas que
se ganan la vida con el negocio de las drogas?
AG: Bien, lo primero es que, en vez de mandar un billón
de dolares en la erradicación de la droga y lo paguen a un
par de compañías de seguridad, deberían dar
este centenar de billones de dolares a las 50
empresas más innovadores del mundo para
pedirles que creen un millón de trabajos. La clave para
la erradicación de la droga es el trabajo. Mira, hay un
hecho muy poco conocido -- los países que tienen una
renta per cápita legal media de 1.000 dolares no
producen drogas.
Lo segundo, textil. El comercio es la clave, no la ayuda. Los
Estados Unidos y Europa nos dan una tarifa del cero por ciento. La
industria textil es increíblemente móvil. Si quieres que
podamos competir con China y atraer
inversión, podríamos atraer probablemente cuatro o seis
billones de dolares muy fácilmente en el
textil, si hubiera tarifa cero. Crearía el
tipo de trabajo. El algodón no compite contra el opio. Una
camiseta sí. Y necesitamos entender, es la
cadena del valor. Mira, y el afgano de a pie está enfermo
y cansado de escuchar sobre el microcrédito. Es
importante. Pero lo que las mujeres y hombres corrientes que
participan en la micro-producción quieren es acceso global.
No quieren vender a los bazares caritativos
que son sólo para extranjeros, sabes, y la
misma estúpida camisa bordada una y otra vez. Lo
que queremos es una asociación con las marcas de
diseño italiano. ¡Sí, tenemos los mejores bordadores del planeta!
Por qué no podemos hacer lo que se hizo con el norte de
Italia? ¿Con el sistema "Put Out"? Pienso
que económicamente el tema crítico es realmente
pensar sobre ello ahora.
Y lo que diré aquí es que la ayuda no funciona.
Sabes, el sistema de ayuda está roto. El sistema de ayuda
no tiene el conocimiento, la visión, la
habilidad. Estoy totalmente a favor -- después de todo, he alzado
un montón -- sí, para ser exacto, sabes,
traté de persuadir al mundo de que tenían que darle
a mi país 27.5 billones. No querían darnos
el dinero.
CA: e incluso así no funcionó?
AG: No. No. No es que no funcionara. Es que un
dólar de inversión privada, a mi juicio, es
igual al menos que 20 dólares de ayuda, en términos de
la dinámica que genera. Lo segundo es que un
de ayuda podrían ser 10 céntimos, podría ser
20 céntimos, o podría ser 4 dólares.
Depende de en que forma viene, que grados de
condicionalidades que están unidos a ello -- ya sabes, el
sistema de ayuda, al principio, fue diseñado para beneficiar
a los emprendedores de los países desarrollados, no para
generar crecimiento en los países pobres. Y esto
es, de nuevo, una de esas asunciones. La manera en que
los asientos de los coches son una asunción que hemos heredado en
los gobiernos. Creerías que el
gobierno de EEUU no pensara que las empresas americanas
necesiten subvenciones para funcionar en países
en desarrollo. Provee fondos. Pero lo hacen. Hay un
peso entero de historia de ayuda vis a vis que ahora
necesita ser reexaminado. Si el objetivo es construir
estado que puedan valerse por si mismos de manera creíble
-- y estoy lanzando esa proposición igualmente -- vosotros
sabéis que soy muy duro con mis "homólogos", y la ayuda
debe terminar en cada país en un período definido.
Y cada año debe de haber progresos. En
la mobilización de los ingresos internos y la generación
de economía. A menos que a ese tipo de "compactación"
se entre, no podréis sostener el
consenso.